احنا في السعوديه والحديث عن اهم المقومات
الاقتصاديه في هذه المنطقه من مزرعه افاق
الجوف احد اكبر مزارع انتاج
وانتاج زيت الزيتون وكذلك تصديره سلطان
السلمي
يبلغنا نخبه والعصر بارده ولا حاره بارده
يلا تفضل سلطان ايش عندك
قصدك بكر يا عادل
حطنا في مواقف بزوايا يا سلطان قول بدايه
صباح الخير
بدايه صباح الخير عليكم انا كافه مشاهدين
صباح العربيه من شمال السعوديه وتحديدا من
منطقه الجوف ومن داخل مزارع زيت الزيتون
اذا تشتهر مزارع زيت الزيتونه تعد هي
الافضل عالميا او ما بين ثلاثه افضل مناطق
عالميه لانتاج الزيت الزيتون وزراعه
الزيتون بشكل عام نتواجد داخل المزرعه
مساحتها عادل فقط مليون متر مربع نتحدث عن
اكثر من 200 الف شجره زيت زيتون في عوامل
كثير كانت اسباب النجاح لزراعه زيت
الزيتون في السعوديه هي اول شيء الجو احنا
بدايه صيف زي ما انت شايف الجو مغيم نسمه
بروده المياه العذبه والتربه الخصبه
لزراعه زيت الزيتون يمكن اوريكم بعض ثمرات
زيت الزيتون نتحدث انه تبقى على موسم حصاد
زراعه الزيتون قرابه الاربع اشهر في
السعوديه نتكلم انه بعد اربعه اشهر نتحدث
من السعوديه تنتج سنويا
18000 طن سنويا من زيت الزيتون و35 الف طن
من الزيتون المائده كما هو متعارف علي
يغطي 35% فقط
السعودية من الزيتون والجوف تحديدا لوين
تذهب للسوق المحليه ولا بتم تصديرها او
يعني تستهلك محليا
الانتاج الحالي يغطي فقط 35% من انتاج
السوق نحتاج السوق المحلي لكن انا حاستضيف
معايا فيصل الجهني احد الشباب السعودي
المهتم في انتاج زيت الزيتون وزيت او
زيتون المائده بشكل عام انا شايف ميداليات
ذهبيه وجوائز ممكن تحكين عنها بشكل سريع
حياكم الله صباح الخير عليكم وعلى الساده
الكرام هذه طبعا جوائز هناك مزرعتنا افاق
الجوف الحمد لله حنا حاصلين على اربع
جوائز عالميه خلال سنه 22 وعلى جائزتين
خلال 23 من هالزيت الصحي والزيت الزيت
الصحي وجواز عالميه دوليه اخرى لو سالتك
اليوم عن انواع زيت الشعر ثمار الزيت
الزيتون في السعوديه كم نوع هي اكثر من
نوع لكن المتعارف عليه تقريبا اربع انواع
اغلب المزروع الان نوعين اللي هو
الاربوسانه والاربوكينه هذا هذا المتعارف
عليها الان ليش زيت الجوف يعتبر من افضل
ثلاثه زيوت للزيتون في العالم والله هو
افضل زيت تقريبا من
فوائده اصلا فوائد الزيت المعروفه من غير
هذا جوده الزيت هنا بطبيعه ارض الجوف شكرا
لك فيصل يعني زي ما انتم شايفين اعداد
كبيره من ثمار زيت الزيتون يعني يهتم
اهالي منطقه الجوف بزراعه الزيتون نظرا
للطبيعه والارض الخصبه وكل التفاصيل
المناسبه لزراعه الزيتون في السعوديه لذلك
نشاهد اهتمام كبير من قبل جهات المعنيه
وكذلك هذه المنطقه بانتاج زيت الزيتون
وزيتون المائده شكرا جزيلا لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات